and the fact that you usually dress like
seth rogen although
you make it cute sometimes we're gonna
disagree with you there jules
roo's outfits give us actual life even
if she does sometimes dress like seth
rogen
in fact the fashion from everyone in
euphoria is
well euphoric that's why in this video
we're covering some of their best rave
ready looks
glitter and all love that speaking of
rue
i'm rue it's safe to say she dresses for
comfort
but that doesn't mean we are not
absolutely jealous
of her everyday outfits they are
effortless but
really reflect her nonchalant attitude
we see her pulling off some wild
patterned button-ups and an oversized
tie-dye t-shirt we'd give
anything for euphoria's costume designer
heidi bivens admitted that roo's
wardrobe is actually a statement on how
clothing really is gender-neutral
the carnival that happened in episode 4
of the series is
intense both emotionally and fashion
wise
rue's outfit is pretty on brand but the
magic lies in her makeup
throughout the series we usually see rue
bare-faced and beautiful
but in this episode she has glitter
triangles underneath her eyes not only
was the look aesthetic
it was also meaningful the glitter was
actually supposed to represent the tears
and emotional journey she goes through
in the episode speaking of breaking
gender norms
the costume department took that all to
the next level with roo's halloween
costume
on the forefront she looks like she
dressed like someone in a tuxedo
but fans have theories that she was
meant to be marlena dietrich
from the film morocco who ironically is
a 1930s icon for being androgynous
another fun fact rue's costume was
actually a little boy's tuxedo
wow okay roo gets a little help from
jules with her winter formal look
but you can't tell us the outfit
wouldn't have looked as epic
if it wasn't rue wearing it this might
be the most traditionally feminine
outfit we see her wear
but in rue-like fashion she pairs the
dress with an oversized blazer and a
pair of tights
somebody get her on the cover of vogue
already thank you
of course jules couldn't have come up
with rue's winter formal look without
being unfairly fashionable herself
she was actually meant to be eye candy
to the camera her anime inspired
wardrobe and out of this world makeup
was like a breath of fresh air in an
otherwise pretty dark series
she was so unapologetically herself even
in the way she dresses
it's inspirational just like roo's
glitter tears
jules looks represented her mood and
changed when she did
her looks get more whimsical when she's
falling in love
remember her cloud eye makeup roo this
is the difference between
like you and me iconic but when we leave
jules
she's going through a bit of a dark
period her cotton candy pink hair turns
into black highlights
and we even see her cry neon orange
tears in the city club during episode 7.
we saw a completely different side of
jewels here jewel's winter formal look
is also a far cry from her short skirts
and crop tops we see her wear at the
beginning of the series
the two sparkly pieces are more mature
and sophisticated
while also being so perfectly suited to
jewels
according to the costume designer her
fashion change is
actually because she's no longer
dressing for approval from men
she's dressing for herself as she
should jules looked ethereal in her
angel costume during the halloween party
but she was more than just an angel
thank you don't really
feel it but you know the costume was
actually a replica of juliet's costume
in the 1996 romeo and juliet movie
not to be a downer but does anyone else
think this could have also been a subtle
hint at the doomed relationship between
jules and rue
this might be jules's most fierce look
not only is the two-piece she's wearing
loud in the best way
but her makeup is literally out of this
world which makes sense
considering it's all happening in rue's
imagination who even came up with the
idea of gluing spikes around her eyes
we're not complaining we're just
impressed cat starts off as a quiet teen
his fashion is very thrifty and very on
brand for gen z
her outfits were actually inspired by
thora birch's character
in ghost world but as her character
grows into a confident independent woman
her wardrobe follows just look at the
contrast between the first few episodes
and the end of the series
also can we please discuss the red
outfit she struts them all in
somebody get her a runway cat's
halloween costume is also
a far cry from the fan fiction writer we
met in episode one
cat dresses as a nun which is
hilariously ironic
considering what she's doing online but
she wasn't just
any nun i'm santa from miz45
she was a character from the film ms45
that follows a woman who gets her
revenge
after being objectified by men fitting
kat brought back the red for this outfit
and we're not complaining
her dress was even mom approved the
leather the straps the fan
was everything she was red fierce and
unstoppable her neon makeup was the
finishing touch and
very euphoria maddie's everyday looks
are all in the makeup
she's the jewel and winged eyeliner in
all colors queen
her outfits drip confidence no matter
what she wears
let's be real she could wear a bag and
we'd still be placing a crown on her
head
whether it's her adorable fuzzy
two-piece or epic cheerleading looks
any scene maddie is in her clothes come
to slay
we couldn't go through this entire video
without talking about maddie's outfit
from the carnival
nate might have disapproved go home
get changed and come back looking like a
person but does anyone really care what
nate thinks
we're kidding kind of the two-piece with
the leg cutouts was
everything maddie stands for confidence
and being unapologetically
you maddie's winter formal look has way
more meaning behind it than we
originally thought
it was basically a political statement
her dress was inspired by rose mcgowan's
mtv outfit back in the 90s
the actress wore it to make a statement
about her harvey weinstein allegations
the dress is kind of perfect for maddie
considering the situation she was in
with nate
not to mention she looks perfect
maddie also brought up a controversial
look for her halloween party costume
she was dressed as iris from the film
taxi driver the movie deals with her
being trafficked as a teenager
but this also ties in well with maddie's
backstory
can we also take a second to appreciate
how epic her
eye makeup looked for this costume
cassie doesn't really
have a specific sense of style love that
and honestly we love that for her she
dresses depending on who she's trying to
impress
where she's trying to fit in or just
overall for how she's feeling
that doesn't mean her looks aren't the
cutest though she's very experimental
isn't that what high school's for anyway
when we learn that cassie has a
background in figure skating
she's going through a really rough time
and the scene in her fantasy where she
has this perfect costume on with sequins
and all
not to mention perfectly placed gems on
her entire body
was meant to be a direct contrast to
what she was going through at the clinic
it was beautiful and tragic all at the
same time
cassie's halloween look was very on par
with the rest of her wardrobe choices
if you didn't realize who she was meant
to be she was dressed as alabama worley
from quentin tarantino's film
true romance she may have conceded to
covering up for mckay's college party
but at cats she was a hundred percent
her authentic self
is it too much no absolutely
not wow there's no deep meaning behind
cassie's winter formal look
it was just pretty and pink and feminine
the slip dress was a gen z
dream let's be real looking at this
dress we could totally tell that the
creators
weren't lying when they said they took
fashion inspo from instagram
nonetheless she looked stunning it's
true
euphoria has broken the norm when it
comes to young adult television
that includes their bold fashion choices
they make the eccentric blend in with
gen z seamlessly
what was your favorite euphoria look is
it even possible to choose
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a like
we'll catch you later thanks for
watching